48 heures après le passage de la tornade
qui a causé de nombreux dégâts le
village de saint nicolas de bourgueil
tente de se relever son église a été en
grande partie détruite la note
s'élèverait à 10 millions d'euros une
cagnotte est lancé thibaut bruch
après le temps de l'émotion
celui de la reconstruction à saint
nicolas de bourgueil les dégâts causés
par le passage de la tornade dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche sont encore
bien visibles sur place la priorité est
donnée à la sécurité des habitants du
village
nous sommes intervenus ce jour ce lundi
sur la commune de saint nicolas de
bourgueil afin de sécuriser les éléments
de toiture et de couverture comme les
antennes télé
des éléments au zinc qui permettent de
couvrir les bâtiments dans le village
l'église et certaines habitations ont
été touchées
mille six cents foyers ont été privés
d'électricité et de nombreuses familles
contraintes d'être relogées pour les
riverains
la surprise est totale chez très
impressionnant moi j'ai je me sente huit
ans c'est la première fois que je vois
ça demain dans ma vie la touraine c'est
un pays est calme et l'âge est très
surprenant une tornade un phénomène
climatique exceptionnel en indre et
loire
mais qui n'est pas réservé aux grandes
plaines américaines et surtout très
difficiles à anticiper
pour les spécialistes ça arrive une fois
heureusement ça arrive très rarement
mais on en a déjà connus et la
difficulté pour nous c'est d'arriver à
prévoir ces phénomènes qui sont
extrêmement localisé est liée à des
circonstances très particulières liées à
l'environnement immédiat du nuage
saint nicolas de bourgueil et ses
habitants se remettent doucement de leur
terrible nuit et une demande d'état de
catastrophe naturelle a déjà été déposé